three
ah
bringing ding ding ding dang bring three
if you're listening to this on instagram
and that makes sense i hope whoever
composed that song is is living very
comfy welcome to the show by the
way scott paul lauren welcome to the
show stop paul laura and i'm scott
paul laura i'm scott paul lauren and
you introduce yourself i'm scott ball or
enforce you not about stage name not
a good stage name how about lawrence
scott paul that's pretty good too
two more in paul scott off the
lady's name should go hi i'm scott
ho lauren i'm paul law i'm paula
power can i tell you so okay
lauren scott we're about it full disclosure
we're recording back to back episodes this
what we do we're standing you think
we get a little weird is probably
because they're why i think you and
i lauren or maybe in the same
place because i got very little sleep
last night what happened oh you know
what though ma you're
you're wrestling with your conscience yeah
what happened to someone i stole stuff
from my wife what did you steal
like jokes all her jews ah newby
said to jo and her underpants independent
i sold her jewels rubies ah some
jokes was there lamb her underpants some
jewels some underpants all her jokes stop
making a plural sorry
that's a shirt that's a shirt stuff
i needed blair brought to you by
that's a shirt was there a panty
raid going on there was a panty
raid remember when that was nothing really
why did you sleep i i went
to a dodgers game last night with
some fun powells and you just kept
thinking about the crowd well like the
crack of the bat i
and there were fireworks after the game
what do you make the sound of
the horse comes out in the field
there is no rules against it
kill
i think we're both punchy i think
we're both very so so you yield
four hours of podcasting in one day
because i can
where you went to one baseball game
and you can't sleep yeah yeah you
couldn't stop think about how you wish
you were play your the t oh
that would be so fucking awesome if
i was out there i'd catch all
the balls it's gonna be the bad
boy i'd be so proud i wanna
be the mascot i was a bad
boy once i tell you that no
the the dodgers don't have a match
ascot so what's the problem you couldn't
see because now they don't have here's
this is what i gonna have a
draft dodger as the mass
trump is the mascot ah say evading
being grabbed with bone spurs
oh boy would be a funny mascot
same as god just comes limping all
the cow like oh a vicious a
little poor i can't do anything fun
because my bone spurs
why couldn't you say i'm moving to
canada i can't so i went to
the game had a great time with
friends we were sitting in a very
lively section which when that happens and
the and the like you're you're seated
around strangers that are also having a
fun time when they're the right kind
of fun people it's really enjoyable
right because some people are just loud
there yeah they're yelling shit i also
hate when you go to a baseball
game when people are impolite i don't
to the to the to the game
or to the player oh that shit
is so stupid i don't like it
so stupid it's also that's not the
kind of game that baseball yeah when
you're like yelling ensue
old set of players an aggressor even
that way it's like a thing from
movies you feel like oh and his
in real wow i mean there's a
certain type of fan who goes to
a game and then like tries to
boo and insult people as much as
pasta girl stands yeah why didn't you
sleep so we had a great time
it's like fireworks yeah like your third
fireworks after the game so i couldn't
just which adds time finally get home
yeah janie is like already going to
bed when i get home and then
i have the house to my dr
schaeffer hell no she didn't go to
the game oh i see oh so
we don't she has her own life
i'm so sorry to assume that it's
not your not everyone
oh there was oh cool up has
been here for the past few shows
just silently in a corner my friend
let whatever i wish oh well where
did you get marry allows you to
oh so if he didn't let you
you would have done that yeah my
boyfriend says i can have as much
as i like this is like i
have
as many cupcakes as a watch i
get to tell me i can get
coupons on me okay so right so
you're rattling around the house some right
well no rattling hey how come you
put your and i got on your
little cat i've put on my neck
myself and you're rattling around the cuckoo
rice yes i'm hunting my wife and
she's learning the true meaning of christmas
jodie wu j musical goes shady
so let's fund so now i have
that's funny sir the house to myself
and it's nighttime and i'm coming out
at the right time that's perfect time
to be alone i'm coming down from
having a fun time yeah i'm gonna
watch whatever i want on tv yeah
that right where you're like too excited
to go to bed i'm gonna have
a glass of wine going to one
game with little one before i know
it it's like fuck me anyway yeah
oh
two i've watched i've completed watching star
trek discovery the tv show no is
that ah in real life you watched
them discover a new planet i was
invisible part of the yellow shaped like
oh yoshi like it was part of
the ship i mean um and i
had my i had a couple
glasses of wine and i was like
i want i wanted to keep staying
up yeah it's fun there was nothing
stop i needed to be up early
and stopping you i love it thank
god i went to bed when i
did yeah because i fuckin woke up
at seven am i woke up at
three today but wow that's weird have
you been awake since three no no
i went back i went back to
a bed ah approximately six am well
that's where our stories differ girlfriend and
woke back up at eight am i
have to say not because this is
not an advertisement because we're going to
pay for this ad but i got
an hour one of our sponsors on
mores my tv is the hello pillow
i just got mine what is it
slept like a
fuckin right it's filled with hong ra
je la memphis
nah go rock last night i texted
you pictures of bob seger were you
listening to it was you took a
screenshot took a screenshot and i texted
you yes that's her tour our tour
score soundtrack soundtrack gaffe black rock
but to me like a rock when
i see a chevy
i wanna fuck that jails is it
shep forward and like raw eye toward
that's how high
buckwheat and ah l a okay
and they didn't from little rascals and
in particular little eagles preschool from the
little retold rascals and i didn't adjust
all night i wasn't like poke in
my pillow you're saying you went to
sleep but like a dead person you
woke up in the same position i
yeah i really think so i did
that once when i had a mercer
infection maybe i'm
il i had i had a mercy
infection on my fucking face what's mirza
merce i forget what it stands for
but it's a terrible weight it's an
acronym yeah emre say mommy our essay
lands right it's an infection we will
talk too close to the microphone oh
it's m r s a you haven't
effects men's rights men's rights sexual
x got awesome yeah i'm a men's
rights sexual activist and i'm infected with
it what is it that was what
were the symptoms um ah it looks
it looks your symptom it looks like
you have a spider bite maybe or
or a blemish and it just gets
bigger and hotter like temperature huh yeah
like hot to not like sexy
er no more coming her and hotter
people were and everyone's like i touch
that mercil because my reversal was what
could i'd love to fly her so
because she's very forward but just your
mercy will get your story imo my
head shingles to do a lot of
people are single guys there's no immersing
it was very hot can i finish
my more sane
so i was i was wanting living
in new york dragoon best week ever
bet best time to have a crazy
face and oh yeah when you're on
tv really yeah when you are on
best week ever did you always say
this is my best year ever always
they to cut it out of every
episode
my dad's outside dinner he time
i sit at a dinner and on
tv and so i i had this
so i had this thing this before
i realised what it was and i
came home from work you're like i'll
just cute i'm really i said this
is this adorable and you said it's
pretty cute and i said it's adorable
she said it is so hey i
thought i just had like a a
weird
hard like a blemish you know yeah
and was what they call like poppins
it's what they call popular properly gooey
air bubbles i thought i thought ahead
o o g a b so i
come home and i'm really tired and
i said i'm just gonna i'm gonna
like take a nap and i went
when
on star trek discovery and structure discovery
that i knew your nightgown i've painted
myself the same as the wall of
my stub of candle um i i
just lay down the bed in my
clothes and then i woke up the
next day in the exact same position
oh and that's when janey said i
think you should go to the doctor
how many hours
ours is
i must have got home at like
seven or eight okay and then woke
up yeah the next day it can
i think right ooh daddy said i
let you sleep but i think i
should go to the doctor yeah yeah
and you said fuck you i i
sami don't know women don't know i
like my versa this is this man
sleep this is madman
sleep and sleep med man my name
is ryan just sleep all day all
days work yeah i can't believe you
guys don't care i was a dodger
batboy we'll get to it so without
the kinky jeer about everyone to hear
about your shingle had shingles in two
thousand and fifteen i've heard this story
oh yeah i did tell it on
spontaneous nation actually um i had
had shingles from stretches and if people
don't know what shingles is i can
feel it on my background i'm not
going to herpes of the spine you
were working on are you there god
it's me margaret no no i was
unclipped and i address a world premiering
and like there was a lot of
press caused by stress sometime but yeah
i think it's definitely stressed because i
had just gotten a puppy they were
like a lot of things happening in
my life puppies are supposed to make
your life better
it was stressful and i wasn't barely
home so it's like very stressful with
the dog and but there were just
a lot of things happening at once
and i got shingles but i was
at usb and i was about to
ask cat and i was like
i have a lump in my armpit
and i was like oh no i'm
like d'arcy carden like poked it where
i could place we are kind of
like what and then like a good
friend to poke yeah well yeah i
was like is this weird and then
matt walsh was like you should go
to the doctor and i was like
alright you know you don't know women
yeah i'm in when i guess it
was actually i wrote
a thank you letter after because i
feel like it could be so easy
to not take care of your yeah
yeah and it was as if like
a parent had yelled like oh go
get that checked out and then i
didn't it was what i did i
actually didn't do it right away and
i went to go to work the
next day and shoot to show and
like i was like crying because my
back hurt so much because it felt
like someone was holding a hot pan
against me
the back like it was just like
but but third they weren't no one
was there why would someone hold a
hot pan against your back by punishment
anyway this producer told us what was
happening and then he sent me to
the nurse of the warner brothers lot
and they diagnosed me with shingles and
then i had to go get all
these prescriptions and then i still had
to fly to new york and do
like press law for
new york exactly floor lockers a single
show and i did like the red
carpet for jurassic i had shingles like
all the pictures you could see you
can see ah no i just just
know that i'm in great pain right
and um it was just it was
just a horrible experience and then i
honestly when i talk about it i
can feel it like where it was
you could get it three times i
really don't want to get it again
anyway i'm only get three times i
think you can then it's like then
it's out of your system if you
don't you get chicken pox you could
want you can get chicken pox chatbox
once and you can only get shingles
if you've had chickenpox right and i
mean you have it three times had
chicken because i had chicken pox and
if you have the third time
then you pumpkin head appears yeah on
your body pump
do you think it's it i remember
my grandma had it and i was
like this is an old peep i
haven't no i have i have a
family member who currently has it and
i was trying to make them feel
better by saying like oh no i
know a lot of people who have
had it like young people yeah trying
to make them feel bad about not
being like oh i'm old and i
have right shingles and they were like
really how weird for them to have
it it's an old person so this
judge just got people that i know
it's definitely not an old person saying
seth row had it recently on twitter
i saw he mentioned it okay because
that's the person i was talking about
money he when he told me i
was like i had it in my
head like oh that's isn't an old
person yeah he's like oh no
it's ah it's just like herpes in
your spine it's fucking weird yeah um
he just figured out instagram stories and
i'm finding it delightful oh cool oh
i'll get in there one of these
days yeah char right batboy lives here
yeah so what happened on the field
let's go weekly world news to the
story of
bad boy i get it was that
fresh seen the musical what was batboy
from this yes yes
i bet you're bringing up saying for
like five minutes okay so what happened
scott hurry up okay i'm late okay
so
by the way i i brought this
up to you guys i don't know
how you actually felt about it but
i think if we ever if we
ever so start to tell a story
we've already told on this show there
should be a punishment yes thinking i
was making seven shank seven will spank
and it's gotta be like it's gotta
hurt or worse infection
you want to be spent
if it if you tell a story
twice or more than once kevin spank
scott ways yeah oh and we because
it's painful to watch someone gets bang
because scott likes it a lot so
um so i'm hoping i didn't tell
this but i've told i've told you
about how bad dasher and dancer production
mix i've heard it
but i've told you about how poor
of a baseball player i was yeah
yeah oh yeah and forty or form
you'd lost all your money in baseball
you pulled out completely and rose a
moth flew out of your wallet yeah
um sorry declined so my my father
used to go to this um lawnmower
repair store i think it was and
movie once ah whether a bunch of
lawn mowers in there that were broken
yeah yeah hey sophie weird selling guide
note if you'd like it i'm able
to tell the story without being two
seconds e flat out wrong but continue
so he used to go to the
slot to lawn oh my god look
look look look look look look look
oh isn't this interesting don't be sad
oh you're a baseball fear i have
a baseball well this i listen to
your dream he's a baseball sandbox body
here too after first year yeah you're
connected to baseball
know what i did and what i
did you would love to do your
your right you ever want to sing
the national anthem at a dodger game
or yeah like i was like i
would like to i'd like to do
that but throughout the first probably throw
it to embarrass me every time i
go i want every time i go
to one of these games at some
like person i've never heard of doing
it it's like fuck we could do
it oh yeah
a can a but but i feel
like i should say do you see
the ration nice guys now is like
my baby i was like you planned
them to hang me out to dry
while i hang me out to dry
cold work is um but i ok
wrong but i feel like we just
need the right publicist or something in
order to do this anyway to get
to the conversation know
okay so my cheek by publicists because
of this podcast my dad went to
this lawnmower store they were having a
competent not a competition contest where if
you don't count those beauty conscious he
wants a second place they'll all lawn
mowers are equally attractive disagree you want
to see
grass yeah baby if there is grasso
boiled if there's grass in the bag
it's worth two in the show oh
yeah baby yeah yeah yeah yeah baby
oh you make your harney do you
play make you horny baby yarn joining
yeah already miller ja harney mary
do i make you horny baby your
favorite show broadchurch do i make your
hire name mueller
yeah roger i've talked about roger
like i said i did um ok
so there was a contest if you
filled out if you filled out a
form ah you could ah they they
pulled from at the end of like
a month or whatever they pulled from
this jar that all the forms are
in and if if you want to
drive if you won you are able
to ah what are we
we talking about okay you g you
would be the dodgers batboy for a
game okay um so and we knew
people who like put in forty like
every time they went to the store
they would put it in a thing
and so they put in forty of
these and my dad went once and
he put me and my brother in
and i want what were their excuses
for going to this loss
over and over check out ya the
bottom of this longboard it's like kind
of acting funny and he knew a
little morrison
twelve celtic back to more so i
won and i'm immediately like haldia ah
eight and i and i have just
fear because yeah because i'm sure i
would've been terrified i'm not terrible do
that i'm terrible at baseball part of
part of it is part of it
is is you get a dodger uniform
yeah
yeah and you keep to keep and
use it the spoke and you can
still get it
you don't get a baby's uniform what
do you oh wait i can tell
now
i thought you meant then
where did you go with that
i think because your body is as
small as it was here yeah i
thought you meant you can pause it
wasn't grey yeah body is small as
it was when you were eight
but most of all i'm i'm scared
not because of the responsibilities or whatever
but i'm scared that when i tell
everyone i told you about the car
we'll contest ah i'm scared that i'm
spanking so yeah
i'm saying i know i told you
about this i i'm scared that when
i tell people that i won this
admittedly cool thing and this is what
happened everyone would say you don't deserve
that you suck at baseball okay and
that's exactly what happened huh
no um everyone said and i was
i was on a baseball team you
know when they were like and i
told them about it and they're like
well you're the worst fucking player on
the indonesian say fuck you're the worst
player on this team we're flipping player
on this fifty's team
and they they would say like well
this person deserves it not you you
know stuff like that so that did
happen so anyway but i just want
to talk about the experience because it's
really cool because i sure would like
it okay so ah and in my
mind i'm sort of like okay so
i gotta run out there and get
the bats like after they hit the
ball you know i'm like thinking about
yeah you're right so i get there
and um i find out that i'm
the honorary batboy that my responsibilities are
like judges row that makes more sense
wig yeah exactly
winston churchill is like shouting gavle pick
i'm bad point of order apples that
look like bats yeah there is in
in new york yankee stadium there's a
section called the the judge's chamber there
is for aaron judge fans and they
everyone has a novel they wear fucking
some people have big foam gavels and
they all
wear black robes okay how about this
a t-shirt that says like beautiful script
honorary batboy i am and there's no
assure of like a bat like the
animal yeah yeah yeah i know your
body and a boy and a bat
and it says and there's some there
was and there's an apple it's actually
guy spy book and the zoll kinds
stuff on it so so here's here's
the experience before the game gets to
go out on the field and go
talk to every player on the team
and get them to sign a baseball
and this is the seventy eight dodgers
who are the world champs so we're
talking to steve garvey oh my god
you haven't yawn right into fucking microphone
i said whoa
oh yeah oh yeah i thought you
meant when i was running were yawning
what you said but i was still
interested i just was yawning i'm high
motion movie but we're talking steve garvey
ron say like harvey was steve harvey
is like playing he's like zabel mustache
he would take a swing at a
ball that he would mug for like
five minutes come on he's great though
so i never said he wasn't racist
what so yeah because what take a
picture with all the players like professional
pictures with a professional photographer not just
like you know my parents with their
lane camera or whatever like a professional
photographer comes over to
takes pictures with everyone there was also
a fuck your parents by the way
there later lambert there's stupid your mom
and hell hey wow to full i'm
sorry yeah um so and then there
was another one who another person who
won who is a girl and i
couldn't remember whether
i can't remember i can't remember whether
it was a boy girl in ah
this wouldn't be fucking crazy if they're
like now fuck now mate there's grass
on this field fuck this grass this
field means anyone can fuck here to
stand always there's grass field and anyone
could fucking just say one thing if
i want to say well memories you
listen you listen good this grass feeling
when confronted logs everybody hi bird there's
grass on this veil my mouth full
of blood
to go fuck to feel making a
fuck here mary ah what you lost
all the money want to fuck out
of fear or tos brazile is filled
everyone's fucking as croesus be allowing fuckin
um so that's before the game and
then during the game now it was
probably like right his way because sure
there's a boy
a girl there's a boy and a
girl but i don't know what no
i don't know whether there's what you
are i don't know whether there's a
boy girl ando and a girl winter
wolf
i say i don't know whether it
is a boy girl i don't know
whether there's a boy winner and a
girl winner i don't know whether they
took like two it was two separate
jars or whether the two people they
picked happens to be a boy
so i so here's the cool part
that i think you'll like before the
game they announced and our honorary batboy
in batgirl for the gain is scott
aquaman and this chick and
didn't namer
what if i still wandered off scott
like an tiffany branson he never forgotten
like i wonder if she is giving
branson and we got to go out
to home plate and tip and they
said tip you're like you know do
tip our camera and wave at everyone
and i was so fucking nervous for
that yeah sure yeah and but i
went out there and
tip my cap and i imagine everyone's
like fuck you this is ninety seventy
eight when that was cool very cool
but then i got to go into
those like sort of like seats by
the dugout that are that have the
private food and all that kind of
stuff and got to eat whatever the
fuck i wanted for three innings and
no one could see because its prime
yeah
yeah no because see what a fucking
pig i am what a little piggy
i am don't think i lived on
fucking shovel food in my fat mouth
and then um and then for three
innings we got to be there and
then they were like ok we gotta
take you to your real get out
here oh and those were those were
the second level and i was kind
of like what the fuck it can't
be down on the first level but
still like amazing steady salary we're paying
you would you would guide so you
chose so yesterday my chosen i have
a jar yeah suddenly you're like
watch from the ground floor ah hey
paul spilled everything but like he'll use
his bag away but ah holy shit
oh it's already wet why not screw
up i like to think of reasons
so anyway
so we get this is an afternoon
day is a day game where we
get back at my dad is like
hey you wanna throw the ball around
because we just moved into our new
house which was right three houses down
from a park ah and he's like
you wanna throw the ball around and
i know i know this is more
for him than for me because
i'm terrible at baseball but i'm like
yeah i sure do and i go
and we're just and i'm trying to
throw the ball and i'm like you
know terrible at it and then these
two we just moved into the house
i know no one in this neighborhood
these two kids come over and see
me wearing the uniform and they're like
hey why are you wearing that
a uniform and my dad's all you
guys want throw the ball around and
so we like all throw the ball
around and they're all like oh this
guy's sucks at baseball but but ah
they became my best friends for negligence
ah ok five years until they moved
away well that's that's a lovely and
nice thing i never change shining really
worried near the end i never would
have met these kids if i hadn't
been wearing that daughter uniform and they
were like ah like wondering why i
was i have this like exact dodger
uniform and then we wouldn't have met
today yes exactly there's
i do believe that well because he
might my one of them was my
best friend for years and years and
we used to do things like fake
radio shows and stuff like that in
his bedroom absolutely and i think it
led me to hear so anyway so
you really wouldn't have met so you
know hearing who cares that i suck
at base
ball well and this was a traumatic
experience bothers me a little bit that
i may as well be good now
ah let's play one on one baseball
wow you we each have to pitch
for each other and they have to
be good pitches and i'll keep score
that's right yeah okay because you're a
girl ah okay for either have used
i
because i'm i watch newsday because i'm
white because i'm white i feel like
i'm better
south was awesome
lauren was drinking into her to my
giant drug it was the sound of
me being inspecting the white privilege for
semen semen yeah i'm having one gallon
of semen fucking free do you know
it's impossible to drink at all one
sitting out of c o that's what
they said but yeah rod
stewart's when rob started to go to
the hospital i was always told you
can't have of ten saltines in a
row and you can't have a whole
piece of cinnamon and a spoon and
you can't even sit a minute in
the spoons and can't drink and you
guys have kind of waka and i'm
proving them all wrong time and time
again you can't fold the paper in
half more than
twice five twenty one two buckle my
shoe yeah oh wait you love ryan
we need to take a break we'll
come back because i kind of say
i don't know but i i'm fascinated
by it so my best friends but
we design oh because you're white know
you're watching something but we got yeah
we go come back we'll go come
back to it alright we'll see on
the other side of this
and we're back hey paul here what
because i watch i watch baseball because
i'm white i watch baseball on the
computer i watch baseball via the um
m l b the m l b
app imo be at bat as you
have two starting to
get into the team accept your apology
ah do you have to subscribe to
like directv and then they'll give you
every game or the or the direct
t v package or some oh no
my brother you have to get your
own okay here's how it works i
have wire cable packages directv that's how
we get our television and all that
shit yeah
which is why i mentioned it yes
why didn't know if i was okay
i've been to your house and have
watched okay so i didn't know if
you memorized are capable that's the first
thing that i squeeze me yes miss
alma what you have to pay to
watch baseball specifically there well i there's
local game there's certain tag
it was weird it feels like it
should be on like streaming on a
certain channel all the time well that's
your generation when you think everything should
be free here's where we come i'm
saying is i think that if it's
a baseball game it should be free
because i could smell upon it so
wiring and it's so boring nobody here
here's where we come to it is
that ah because of ah the deal
that the
league made with you know whatever fuckin
conglomerate with comcast i guess i love
comcast if well it's my favorite if
you love comcast you can watch the
dodgers i love how every field is
named like in chicago now it's us
cellular field such wag why don't come
such a drag like just keep just
own it
own it but call it something cool
for the sears tower being the willis
tower i found annoying and then i
only realised this year that sears the
company owned it before right yeah yeah
i was like i like you went
to sears tower that's like that's like
me saying like i like it when
it was us cellular it's like what
am i holding on to yeah i
agree though i wish they they think
the empire state building was one ah
no no no no
and that's where the all the basketball
signed by michael jordan and are you
guys remember that i don't know
back in the day at least on
chicago the local commercial empire was that
you would if you call and got
carpet you also got a free basketball
simon michael jory how much did they
pay him for that hello there i'm
gonna play like printed like it was
like yeah just got michael jordan basketball
oh not signed by him it was
come to your home but he was
like where is it
today isn't why did i make this
shitty deal no remarkable either if he
was in the commercial or wishes to
cut out of him in the commercial
oh i bet he got paid even
for the cut-out yeah yeah greedy fuck
i love my dorna sure you do
you're from chicago moore's you have to
i'm i'm ever suspending i know nothing
i know nothing negative basically about him
the same times i have heard stuff
i'm like i'll forget that yeah mission
accomplished yeah
um so you watch baseball on your
ah yes so it'll be up yeah
because you can't watch you can't watch
dodger games on local tv unless you
have comcast yeah there there's just there's
no way which is yeah which is
but occasionally won't they be on like
channel five or something or are they
no longer if they get into the
postseason right i think if everyone's like
we're we're giving you a game
oh lucky also there's the thing where
if it doesn't sell out then they
blacked out well now it's blacked out
no matter what yeah but you know
what i mean like where where like
they want to sell tickets to the
local games yeah and if they don't
sell it out they won't show it
on tv because they're like well you
assholes should come to the game then
they also will nine lower the prices
of tickets and come out people who
literally can
can't go that one day watch it
that it barrio a hospital bums me
i love baseball yeah so but all
are really fucking job that does not
allow you to like yo kids and
yes go on the radio seconds there
yes you can listen listen to radio
the radio look you know there's also
no okay if you want to be
a step more boring and listen to
it on the radio
what it couldn't couldn't an old person
also describe it to someone over the
phone i will yeah yeah free describe
it to you where he's going pc
looks like he wants to hit what
a nice young man
the country is heap they were all
wearing the same clothes i don't know
who's
um e the actually the radio broadcast
of dodgers games is better than the
tv bro my dad yeah because with
the weird thing about rate baseball on
the radio is it sounds exactly like
it did a hundred years ago like
when you're when you're a sick boy
so when you're sick boy in the
hospital and you have pleurisy
e and like cancer you're waiting for
a rich man to adopt you that's
right you can't do plurals oh so
you say i like ice cream cone
so grape so i want love grape
can i have grape
i watch via the mlb app and
so you see the same if you're
watching a game live you can't fast
forward through the ads and it's the
same ad over and over and over
again it's like power friends you get
the same we talked about this if
you yeah chevron is ready to spank
me he's got his paddle out um
i don't know
sometimes we will watch best basketball basketball
players keep realize subscription thing known to
be sure exactions they block out the
commercials they just put like oh yeah
just like nva on the screen yeah
because those commercials are not being paid
for i love it it's the most
calming moments you guys sit there and
be like because basketball
games are so tense in the early
in the earliest i'm reward the whole
time so i'm like oh oh really
what are you not bored during island
this is a good game what does
lauren not fucking
that's your time but that's the only
time i perk up is when i'm
doing what i want when i want
to make clear i'm not really bored
i actually can enjoy basically anything i
like watching basketball like watching baseball blah
blah blah it's the kind that you
keep its accompanying habe and i have
fun with my mike bores you know
mike is fun oh i'm see that's
why
i don't care i'm guy on tv
yeah but you so you could do
you could do anything i know i
make i don't care what it is
but i'm just saying i can complain
surely you can do that too
you do anything these days you put
your mind i don't know if i
would enjoy that the next day like
you just complaining about what we did
feels like i don't actually never complain
i'm actually just wonderful
oh okay i'm sorry i didn't know
it okay
i don't complain so you're watching i
complain about very here's a tale of
two commercials there's one commercial that's very
adorable dickensian where it is
there's one there's one i'm ripping this
off from dickinson wright has one commercial
there's one still taylor tooth
go on so there's one commercial it's
very precious for amazon
oh oh sorry yeah sorry sorry i'm
fucking my no on pulses
this is the low point for me
so sorry sorry sorry to be fair
lawrence started
noise an accident real you
okay tale of two commercials oh i'm
sorry what commercials very adorable for amazon
where dad is what if it's like
this girl gets this little girl gets
into baseball so she's like on the
sidelines ball she's watching a game ball
rolls over near her they say hey
can you throw that ball over she
throws over
they're like oh she's got she's got
a good you got game next you
see her she's on the pitcher's mound
but she doesn't have the right equipment
so the father is making notes of
things doctor first yea gives her a
jock strap put on her head i'm
gonna smell this that's right and he
says you're a girl getting the kitchen
so first he makes he makes a
note that he has to buy her
her a glove than he makes an
odious to buy her cleats why does
he have to make these nodes of
course he has a bio yeah it's
like what are the basic ones dumb
shit for bass he's entering it into
the amazon search berg like send you
to have to write it down i
didn't really think of it that way
think of it that way now now
i get it
amazon so then by the end of
the commercial he's yeah it wasn't amazon
commercial yeah okay so then by the
end of the commercial he she's asleep
she's in full uniform asleep in the
backseat of the car she's still on
the field to sleep he's taking too
long full uniform asleep in her bed
with her mirza
time to change
i really commercial i'm a little girl
i'm in the commercial i'm a little
girl two separate thoughts now you guys
are the condition and your little girl
what game are we playing this is
a feature you guys go a little
commercial
okay so actually she's in bed oh
no she's not in my sleep asleep
toggle the dash looks over there we
see she's got a big trophy next
to her they have just you know
she's no champion baseball player right dad
is very proudly makes a note to
buy a trophy shelf very ah i
love it darling i'm
crying other commercial yeah this is the
flip side of the opposite there so
it's a mom it's notes are sons
a loser an old man
it ends it's not my griefs
this is actually the same you don't
see people in shorts a sql yeah
typical conversion is like alleged to put
flowers on coffin
okay amazon dotcom back during coffin search
you said confident made me cough
your search is over so
so this commercial it's like dramatic so
like sports voiceover john cena style you
know this oh no statue will be
erected following this suse
wow this is halloween merrill halo pumpkin
king mary o bir de tal away
oh so this is all we have
schelling did not have my watch mary
i'm just mixing everything up
i
so this woman is running she's in
a business suit she's got like a
name tag on she's running what kind
of shoes she's avoiding sensible shoes okay
so it's like a low heel okay
her like like dance shoes joggers low
heels okay got it
probably easy spirits okay train beer pumps
got it looks like puppet feels like
sneaky i'm sure
so she's running get to it has
got to oh i'm so sorry oh
this from that boy
if this bad boy this from boy
what's wrong with bad boy t f
b b what's wrong with the badger
oh hello with a bad boy it's
me so there so the voice-overs saying
no there's never gonna be a statue
of her she's never going to be
in the hall of fame you know
um so basically it's this it's it's
a commercial for sheraton i think where
this woman works at this hotel is
running to get this baseball glove to
this little kid who forgot the glove
in the room or whatever oh yeah
like socials where that kid falls in
the pool on the person link or
they dropped their stuffed animal
the big calls up the emergency child
was drowned but she's a hero she's
young she's not in the hall of
fame but she's the unsung hero of
getting glove about mary ah yeah but
it's it's what's so weird is the
the the tone of the commercial like
it is basically isn't it so funny
we're treating this
ah you're like a sports hero yeah
yeah like the other ones like hopefully
you know little girls can grow up
to be sports heroes if they ever
yeah like there's nothing yeah like yeah
yeah girls are allowed to play sports
yeah exactly they're the other one is
is like facetiously yeah oh in this
crazy universe like women are treated like
sports hero she's sliding like as if
like
that's a thing that men do in
baseball yeah but but it actually contains
the phrase she was just a woman
who cared enough to whatever but does
that long pause it has just a
woman hangs there for such a long
time but it's so weird like as
you're watching sports and there's this idea
that it's like well she's never going
to be no one's ever gonna give
a shit about her later i don't
like it like she's a hero but
you know not like
really it is weird that all of
those sports are only men well you
know or why went with not even
one i went with ria to a
game a year ago or so and
there was a cheated on me there
and we fall know ah she there
was ah there was ah i think
she was like twelve thirteen is i
don't really older than that yeah no
she was twelve or thirteen this was
last year yeah person i think game
you know there was ah there was
one of those um in traditionally i'd
always seen them as like you know
teenage boy
boys one of those people who during
when they're warming up and throwing around
the field what is it what's the
trouble girl yeah yeah yeah yeah and
she was throwing and she you know
she's supposed to go get the balls
thrown but she was throwing so fucking
far yeah like so much further than
like almost as far as the professionals
in the game yeah i was like
well she should just be playing shouldn't
yeah i mean like shit lay you
know i mean in a couple of
years like shouldn't she just why is
there not been one woman baseball player
really weird it's like baseball isn't a
strength spore i mean maybe the batting
part of course you have to be
strong that's why all responsible juice up
so much on pa
possible for a woman to be able
to hit a home run yeah so
like at least ah you know graphical
demo well extremely athletic person it just
seems weird that besides that there's baseball
players who do you know who compartmentalize
who do these one things like i
only i'm a i'm a desert runner
yeah zach you know i do this
one fucking thing yeah you know yeah
like with basketball it makes more sense
in the sense that like some people
are like ben going to be like
men are like seven feet tall and
it's like that's a whole ride and
with acting like best actor and best
actress definitely men are better and stuff
and better at being like faking a
characters and stuff
well there are there are of course
women baseball players and there's a yes
there's a national there's a national team
there's a there's a there's two but
where's there's just women there's a team
yes there's a men's team and women's
team us national team um and but
when i i went to a phillies
game to see the phillies play the
dodgers recently
and janie came with me for this
finally
my week were we were watching the
game and in between she said oh
look the ball girl is throwing two
are they arise viewers no nother it's
way more common that's great it's way
more common like hey yeah i just
wondered if traditionally throughout the years they
were ball girls and i was just
not aware of it know why
i don't know when it changed i'm
sure for the majority of baseball they
were boys but i thought any is
bore but thinking but here's the thing
so she said oh look at that
and and so is either it was
i think it was nick williams the
phillies right fielder between as they you
know as the innings were changing over
when the when the phillies would take
the field
old they were throwing the ball back
and forth so she's by you know
like first base and she's throwing the
ball back to him and i never
either who's on first either either this
was something that did not happen often
or something i never noticed before and
i forgot to look the last time
i went to a game steve have
but they did it
every time every time the phillies took
the field they would throw the ball
until it was time for the the
the inning to start and it made
me so happy to see oh yeah
me so happy to know i love
it and i i i just wondered
when i saw it i was like
well that's great she's got this love
of the game what are they raising
her to be though just
a fan
flailing like that yeah it's weird about
it like that there's no there is
no ability for a woman to be
on a team like that where everyone
sees this game and every exactly to
be on it to be on a
major league team right into to to
get that exposure to play in that
let me play level make that money
yeah exactly that's yeah yeah
but can i make the money you
gotta love the game enough you know
to go out there and get play
wherever you can also they don't let
definitely it's cool that you do it
in different levels they don't they don't
let people like me who are bad
at play either it's like i don't
get it i mean you've got those
two best friends out of it for
five through um we need to go
to another bank okay i don't care
ok i don't care
you don't care to say you love
it i thought
alright we'll see
we're back hi i like you i
like you i like everyone alright let
me say this yeah this is sincere
okay i'm happy to see you guys
i'm happy to see i love doing
the show with you
and i'm so happy to be back
recording i'm second that emotion
scott will you give us a quorum
guys i'm uncomfortable with these feelings i'm
having i don't like to express them
all that much but i love you
guys wow paul you and i have
seen each other more recently than i
feel like lauren yeah yeah because we
went to trump springs show together or
for the memorial day holiday
yes yeah it was fun and my
daughter was born male you were involved
and available i was somewhere i was
in new york or no i don't
know why from new york i had
to get my bbq sauce and my
robberies oh barbecues oh rose barb
a user base that's from new york
city new york so not only this
is the anti new york city bbq
bbq so la for news also no
pay sale because they started mary is
an old maid five from new york
i love the lowest birth scott is
just doing it's just doing where you
lie talking who cares what you guys
have to say look tell us a
feature please i also feature when we
oh shit what do we got future
time i went online to search for
party games first party games took me
to a lot of fucking bored
games nose wow then i realized parlor
game parlor much better yes much better
because that's before things were invented and
people yes replied to shit i'm fill
time you imagine living back then that
sounds better just waiting till it got
dark to go to bed yeah you
just like god for i pray for
the darkness
i miss those days for the dark
i would love to live in the
time with no electricity and i would
die at thirty
i wish you died at thirty you
this
the darkest shitting one's ever seen but
it's the fact that i'm pretty sure
past that point makes it less dark
but um not cool not cool not
cool alright fine i'll take it actually
i'm i'm gonna i apologize i don't
want your post there there's beautiful you
you owe you don't accept it
look i like life i want to
live a lie like life life likes
me yeah
a speaking of scrooge what there is
a game that songs from scrooge the
musical version of a christmas tie didn't
know i just went along with it
lie no i just went along with
i could've drowned stalled
memories because of the tonys know i
i guess probably but i don't not
on purpose did you watch the tony
shit then it's because of the tone
okay well that's the only reason i
have thoughts did you watch videos that
is because at that point oh were
you just somehow dancing all night yeah
i was thinking about my current life
okay car looking cool
well you know what we always we
kind of did this one ah in
the last show don't pick it but
but don't you want to hear what
it is yes why because you say
it's called the sing-song pingpong oh i
like it it's very racist oh decide
early on what type of songs to
use decide who goes first
first with that person singing a line
of a song preferably the chorus always
easier the rest of the group then
think of another song featuring any of
the words currently oh this is so
lobo stuff it's hotspot golden goodbyes and
probably game called hotspot which you've adapted
to be so low bow well we
we perfected it she fuckin exposed you
as a froward
your frau de i am
your penis froward i cooked up famous
frau ja
oh yeah we pray hook your penis
fry up to trapeze i equal wow
i don't want to play it alright
fine don't you like my character the
island yeah i got your frown
okay new game new game scott i
didn't mean to offend you by what
i'm saying that was an improv game
oh you can't advance oh i don't
know i don't care what you say
will try with it was a real
foot up real foot up try i'm
getting evil she was doing eve lauren
was doing evil fingers
but she also raised her foot in
the devil himself would like old square
yourself the devils a man well the
devil were probably a man could enjoy
that task of roasting people in hell
for eternity
because it will mean i don't want
to go shopping in the middle i'm
gonna get multitasking with it and have
so many other things like read the
paper and roast people in hell
alright feature time two don't make a
space speaking of scrooge i'll take this
up so just this is make a
touchdown
remember don't let her deal out and
you can start out to make it
hit the tank better better better better
better
no no no no no no
no no no no hey jude
no no no no no no no
no luck huh
hey joe joe joe joe joe no
no no no
not no
good hey dude no no no no
no no no no no madness
hey hey dude did i tell you
i did a lip-sync to hey jude
yeah you did i did spank him
no you didn't tell me you did
a lip-sync to hate in in ah
in drama slash art class in junior
high one of our assignments was do
a lip-sync you know no dual lipstick
he's got a piece of paper to
do ellipses ellipses thirty eight year teacher's
scrawled on the board trying to do
what ellipses and we have an alexa
at our home and i like to
do a lip-sync
yeah i told i said a reminder
because i needed to leave the house
by certain time and so i you
know i said alexa remind me to
leave at six fifteen and well okay
yeah okay okay i get six six
fifteen the thing says here's your reminder
to leave or whatever but it it
also sent a reminder
or to my phone it said here's
your reminder leave so rude it was
scared aggressive do you like having alexa
okay and their sponsor love um it
it can be fun here's here's the
thing because you can you can tell
it we haven't hooked up to our
lights and so yeah because you love
that feed yeah i've seen that oh
yeah i wanna do that and so
i've made a couple of light recipes
which are like color on ah yeah
yeah yeah and so yeah we
we have colored we have those philips
hue bulbs oh cool this is all
very bougie and um so i i
set up a thing where i would
turn all the lights red if i
say red alert oh cool but you
pretend you're in a summary yes so
so cool i'm punching some cool do
i get to green a new pretender
in a jungle because
fuck yeah what's right but here's the
thing comes this yellow and you put
on sunny ones not what sucks is
it's actually knowing outside
ah
that's cool
ha yeah oh sorry enjoyed you
oh yeah but the thing is alexa
will say okay afterwards so like if
i say i like to read alert
sugar okay and then the lights turn
red wow i just got a red
alert it should be like to com
alexa red alert and then a klaxon
sounds right yeah exactly so why would
anyone want well i would do it
lorentzen you would do in the middle
of apartment with scott hall and second
busy yourself honey okay no no i
don't want to clap no i just
wish it was known i would know
like wouldn't respond like just turn the
lights red can only mean no i'm
sorry i'm dizzy
i've talked to my phone gotten me
a job scheduled the majority would just
go bananas a loco in the cabeza
can i tell you my hey jude
story hey you i commanded you commander
to do list where we left off
yep and everyone you know we're all
like
twelve why didn't we call the show
tangents we're all twelve or thirteen because
it's boring or um the hanging thread
the hanging thread and someone gets hanged
yeah um yeah f a g we're
all like thirteen year old kids and
none of none of them everyone's forced
to take art or drama yeah so
you know nobody's football know these people
are like
i don't want to do it today
no i mean there they'll do it
but they're not there they're just was
really tough like they're like doing a
big running layer whatever yeah anyway so
i come in i'm like oh i'm
gonna do hey jude and you're like
oh um and i i not only
forgot how long the song was no
i didn't edit oh smart
and ah i not only that but
then i also lip-sync an introduction where
me as paul mccartney i did a
paul mccartney spoken introduction you recorded yourself
i recorded myself or i'm like oh
i'm like ooh hello everyone
oh before i sing the song oh
thank you for watching the beatles and
popeye has a few words to say
but i was like ah
do you remember john lennon's last hit
the pavement oh this is nineteen eighty
two two years after my god it
was so sad and and then i
listening to hey jude and i think
i was wearing a costume and no
one else did i'm i'm assuming you
all are you i was thirty fifteen
that
it's thirty thirteen yeah that's that's tough
it's good shit man i and it
killed it didn't get old and i
got an a oh congratulation rate huh
i was on my fucking way bro
that's right bro and i'm here i
may get a house here every day
if you hadn't done that you would
never have met hugo's yeah exactly think
that hey all right do we have
a feature we have a feature called
now this is a longtime reference of
mine because i saw it in the
movie scrooge the musical version of a
christmas carol sponge yourself yeah whoa that's
oliver consider yourself part of the family
waved jack into you so strong
it's clam wow
going into cattle alone to transmit yourself
well in kind don't wanna have hello
yeah i'm not i'm gonna go
da da da da da da da
da da da da
one of us consider yourself at one
of us i thought it was at
home i was about to sing at
home i oh i know sorry okay
i know everything you're about to do
what's in the game thank you uncle
i am a baseball guy from holt
named cooker this is a guarantee she
had a penis so we could chop
it off need it
ah yeah that's the main thing i
wish is that what penis envy is
do women wish they had penises that
could be chopped off and cooked they
look so good
suck it on shiseido ever seen a
peterson thought that looks delicious um sucking
on chili dogs
so honey sucking on chilly dog oh
my oh alright
this is a feature called the minister's
cat oh yeah this is a reference
for you the minister's cat okay interesting
this i've used this as a reference
as a moldy old game that dumb
old fancy people would play oh interesting
okay but now it's actually placing and
now we're gonna play because we're those
dumb people let's pay the minister's cat
all players sit in a circle
i've done the first
shanxi it's easy for shake rooney
the first player describes the minister's cat
with an adjective beginning with the letter
a for example a minister's cat is
an adorable cat
each player then does the same using
different adjectives starting with the same letter
once everyone has done so the first
player scribes the cat with an adjective
begin with letter b this continues each
letter of the alphabet and you have
to say the other one again or
no
no yeah i think you just have
to keep saying memorization game okay ministers
can way i remember seeing it in
the movie was people were okay so
nothing to say the sentence the minister's
cat is an awful cat the minister's
cat is an important cat the minister's
cat is a cunt okay you've lost
the game and my respect sitting about
soulless lawyer but there's
yeah it was too quick because it
was too quick because i'm still fucking
talking all a shit
those fucking mad can vary in an
alternate variation not pulse mad radio
don't do my part
healy did it i didn't really realize
that
in an alternate variation in an alternate
variation the first player describes a minister's
cat with an adjective beginning with a
second with the letter b and so
forth going around the circle
variation i thought that was already something
you said okay no no no first
one's a a this oh we all
say oh gotta gotta yeah and and
so on oh shit cunt you are
wrong oh you said a yeah i
said oh i wasn't paying attention you
sure worked so in a further variation
each player must remember the adjective
vhs which have gone before adding his
or hone his or home his or
home hone is for her own right
yeah yeah it's a contraction is yeah
apostrophe olympiad his or her own adjective
beginning with the next letter of the
alphabet so the fifth player might say
the minister's cat is an adorable beautiful
cute delightful elegant cat
oh that's tough okay let's try it
where we just do a a bb
b ccc station workers fucking funny
where you're there's more um yeah and
all yeah this new crucial your eyes
and mouth and went to sleep so
yeah you'll like you're doing that you've
been asleep for fifteen hours why yes
mirza you have oh mirza oh never
have but that's what i was looking
for thank you was that ah ah
john stamos it was
us
i said but john calvin john stamos
but first opened his first coffee but
first oh the first elvis shots team
of the first elvis you sort of
way i mean all variations of players
out of the game if they are
unable to think of an adjective or
if they repeat one previously used or
can't remember the adjectives which have gone
before
in the last variant okay okay players
may clap in unison or speak in
a rhythmic manner during the game setting
the pace for each player to speak
his line if a player falls to
behind the pace while thinking of an
adjective that may also be declared out
to got it got it okay let's
do it do we want to do
a or abc or abc well you
said you want to do
a so let's just ok joining this
other weird thing okay i don't understand
this on the second and succeeding rounds
and alternate sentence can be used mother's
tea service was brittle mother's tea service
was broken why would you care i
don't i don't know that's why i
guess instead of the minister's cat i
wanna talk about administers cat
religious people but years ago mother fucking
let's do a game okay so we're
gonna do start a little slower a
a or ab ca okay
now now having the arms is bad
this now having arms is bad okay
yeah he's talking he's talking about the
chance to set the pace i'm going
to set the pace
there we go the minister's cat is
an ansi cat i mean this cat
is an antagonistic catch the minister's cat
is an awful cat the minister's cat
is a burly cat the minister's cat
is a beautiful cat the minister's cat
is a big cat the minister's cat
is a childish cat a minister's cat
is a contango cat the minister's cat
is a calico cat the minister's cat
is
dainty cat the minister's cat is a
dangerous cat the minister's cat is a
dumb cat the minister's cat is an
elegant cat the minister's cat is an
easy cat the minister's cat is an
evil cat and ministers kind is a
friendly guy the minister's cat is a
frenetic cat the minister's cat is a
fat yeah matches cause a greasy cat
the minister's cat is gregarious cat the
cat is god
damn catch the minister's cat is ah
hovering yeah lucky the minister's cat is
a handsome cat minister's cat is an
ignorant cat the minister's cat is an
idiot catch the minister's cat is a
jovial cat the minister's guy is a
jolly gacha this guy's kitty cat just
got is a calico cat ah lord
a a you got it you got
it already i feel pretty good well
guys that's all the time we have
really fun the minister's cat i can't
believe i finally played it yeah my
years of being a referee now you
die yeah no no you don't die
no da da don't never die oh
your daddy and the lie yea by
bike
a